avec nous eric alt et des
vice-présidents d'anticorps et
magistrats bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors
agrément renouveler une victoire une
victoire pour la démocratie parce que
nous sommes un petit contre pouvoir je
pense qu'il est important que dans la
dose et démocratie le pouvoir arrête le
pouvoir
donc nous avons ce pouvoir de saisir la
justice notamment lorsque les affaires
ne suivent pas le cours normal qu'on
continue à le faire alors tout le temps
qu'a duré la procédure en le temps que
le gouvernement renouvelle votre
agrément cctv comment s'est passée cette
période à quel point avez-vous douté
nous avons douté à partir du moment où
le délai normal de quatre mois était
expiré ça nous a valu effectivement une
inquiétude préoccupation mais aussi
beaucoup de soutien ont ça nous a
renforcés et un mille adhérents plus qui
nous ont rejoint en janvier février
nous avons une cinquantaine
d'associations qui nous a soutenus nous
avons des îles qui ont adopté des voeux
pour le renouvellement de l'agrément
nous avons des personnalités politiques
qui se sont engagées qui ont même
interpellé le premier ministre au
parlement dont nous avons gagné à la
fois des soutiens et peut-être une
visibilité donc des halles des amis
nouveaux sont apparus à cette occasion
paradoxalement les gens pouvant être
visé par vos actions sont les mêmes à
qui il appartient de renouveler votre
agrément que pensez vous de cette
procédure
je pense que c'est un paradoxe qui
résulte du texte initial et je pense
aussi qu'il ne faut plus que cette
procédure soit politisé à ce point donc
la solution c'est de confier à une
autorité administrative indépendante
le soin de renouveler cet agrément est
peut-être que le projet de loi sur la
confiance dans les institutions
judiciaires
peut-être une occasion adopter une telle
réforme
vos adversaires en anglais de parler
d'eux
reproche de mener un combat partisan que
leur répondez vous d'abord l'association
et trans partisane où toutes les
sensibilités sont sont représentés et
cuit dans nos affaires dont le choix des
dossiers
il y en a pour tous les partis or cela
dit peut-être qu'il envoie un peu plus
pour les partis qui sont au pouvoir mais
c'est dans la nature des choses je peux
les affaires qui ne suivent pas
normalement leurs courses ou plutôt les
affaires qui concerne le pouvoir est un
peu moins d affaires de tout venant ou
des affaires qui concerne l'opposition
mais sinon c'est c'est quelque chose
d'assez important chez nous m trans
partisan donc ça veut pas dire politique
ça veut dire que effectivement tous les
partis dans tous les points de vue on a
intérêt à lui que la correction
ensuite on choisit ce politique que l'on
préfère est d'abord comme une goutte sur
deux possibilités ce débat démocratique
il ya la lutte à la corruption sinon il
ya risque de quoi capter et le biz
populisme alors un agrément qui va
permettre à votre association d'agir
dans des affaires judiciaires de
corruption quelle est la suite de vos
projets maintenant alors d'abord nous
avons environ 515 souci que nous suivons
notamment un certain nombre de dossiers
qui ont été déposés récemment dossiers
importants notamment sur des marchés
publics en matière de santé publique sur
la plateforme de santé publique qui a
été donné sans marché préalable à
microsoft
ça consiste aussi à les voir aller
demander la documentation sur le marché
public
makine c est une société de conseil au
seuil et le gouvernement dans ce
programme de vaccination et puis ça
concerne effectivement toutes les autres
affaires qui sont déjà en cours y
compris même s'ils n'ont pas la
possibilité nous constituer partie
civile devant la cour de justice de la
république est compris celles qui
concernent le
de l'eswc actuelle récup moretti qui est
poursuivie actuellement comprise il ya
un intérêt devant la cour de justice
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes magistrats ainsi
que vice président de l'association
anticor dont l'agrément vient d'être
renouvelé on appris hier soir marcia
vous